the number one lesson I could offer you
where your work is concerned is this I
say to the my girls all of the time that
your real work is to figure out where
your power base is everything that goes
out is coming back wanna be happy
build a life not just the business hey
it's Evan Carmichael and this channel is
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you to you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn six of Oprah Winfrey's
best lessons in life enjoy okay let's
kick it off with lesson number one
master your craft and number one lesson
I could offer you where your work is
concerned as this becomes so skilled so
vigilant so flat-out
fantastic at what you do that your
talent cannot be dismissed stop
comparing yourself to other people
[Applause]
you're only on this planet to be you not
someone else's imitation of you I had to
learn that the hard way on the air live
anchoring the news one night in my 20s
when I first started broadcasting I was
19
moved to an anchor by the time I was 20
and I was just pretending to be Barbara
Walker Walters I was just trying to talk
like Barbara act like Barbara hold my
legs like Barbara and I was on the air
and I hadn't read the copy fully and I
called Canada Canada and I did that on
the air i crack myself up because I
thought Barbara would never call Canada
Canada and that little break through
that little crack that little moment
that I stopped pretending allowed the
real me to come through your life
journey is about learning to become more
of who you are and fulfilling the
highest truest expression of yourself as
a human being that's why you're here
lesson number two get in sync with life
the first law is the third law of motion
in physics which says for every action
there's an equal and opposite reaction
and we showed that very beautifully in
the color purple when Missy Lee says to
mr. everything you even try to do to me
is already done to you that is not just
a rhetorical saying that is law that is
Newton's third law of motion in physics
which says everything that goes out is
coming back it's just like everything
that goes up is coming down may take a
long time to come down is coming down
everything that goes out is coming back
it's coming back so to answer the power
of manifestation and meditation what
meditation does is sync you up with the
source what meditation does is allows
you to literally tap into the power that
created you so that you are in alignment
with that and so when you carry that out
into the world everything that you do
comes from the center of that alignment
that's coming from the source that we
call God we call divine energy divine
intelligence whatever name you want to
give it to do we call life when you are
synched up with life life just gives to
you lesson number three work on yourself
I say to the my girls all of the time
that your real work is to figure out
where your power base is and to work on
the alignment of your personality your
gifts that you have to give with the
real reason why you're here that's
that's the number one thing you have to
do is to work on yourself and to fill
your self up and keep your cup full keep
yourself full now I used to be afraid of
that I used to be afraid particularly
from people who say oh she said she
still has them she's so close or
something and now I embrace it I
considered a compliment that I am full
of myself because you only when you're
full I'm full I'm overflowing my cup
runneth over
I have so much I have so much to offer
and so much to give and I am not afraid
of honoring myself you know it's
miraculous when you think about it
also if you want to have more confidence
check out my 254 series they're free the
link to join under description below to
figure out where your power base is they
think that success
is supposed to happen like that becomes
so skilled so vigilant so flat-out
fantastic at what you do that your
talent cannot be dismissed lesson number
four turn your wounds into wisdom turn
your wounds into wisdom you will be
wounded many times in your life you'll
make mistakes some people will call them
failures but I have learned that failure
is really God's Way of saying excuse me
you're moving in the wrong direction
it's just an experience
just an experience
just an experience I remember being
taken off the air in Baltimore being
told that I was no longer being fit for
television and that I could not anger
the news because I used to go out on the
stories and my own truth was even though
I'm not a weeper I would cry for the
people in the stories and which really
wasn't very effective as a news reporter
to be covering a fire and crying because
the people lost us and it wasn't until
they I was demoted as a on-air
anchorwoman and thrown into the
talk-show arena to get rid of me that I
allowed my own truth to come through and
the first day I was on the air doing my
first talk show back in 1978 it felt
like breathing which is what your true
passion should feel like it should be so
natural to you and so I took what had
been a mistake what had been perceived
as a failure with my career as an
anchorwoman in the news business and
turned it into a talk-show career that's
done okay for me lesson number five
earned success my biggest frustration is
not just with young women my biggest
frustration is also with young men young
people who think that and I have a lot
of this with my girls in college they
think that success is supposed to happen
like the Attucks yeah they think that
there isn't a process to it they think
that they're supposed to come out of
college and have their brand and I
recognize now that I am a brand but I
was resistant to being called a brand
for many years because I was like I'm
brand I'm not a brand I'm a person but
how I got to be a brand was not trying
to be a brand how I had to be a brand
was every day making choices that felt
like this is the right move now that's
the right move and now that's the next
right move the next right move and so my
frustration with young women and young
is that they think it's supposed to
happen like this and they don't
understand that there's a process to it
social media media you did not get to be
editor of Vogue magazine by not working
and working and working and working and
working to get here
I love the theory of that there's 10,000
hours behind anybody who ever gets to be
successful and listen number six the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is have good intentions I was
interviewing a woman on one of the shows
of so impressive for me to see all the
shows that we've done Lord may be tired
looking at it but I was interviewing a
woman it was a show called
the mistress the wise meet the
mistress's or some crazy thing and this
woman was on and it was a live show and
in the middle of it her husband tells
the wife and our entire audience and the
world that his mistress was pregnant yes
to this day makes my eyes water because
I saw his wife's face and I felt her
humiliation and I said I will quit TV if
I have to do this I won't do this
anymore and my producers like what are
we gonna do this is what everybody's
doing and then that same during that
same time period so I said I'm not gonna
do anything like that anymore I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna bring people on TV
and words of Iguala but we didn't know
that moment was gonna happen they were
like we didn't know who's gonna happen
but that should not happen on television
and I do not want to be a part of the
energy that caused somebody to feel that
because that's now gonna come back to me
I got to pay for that then I was
interviewing the KKK on stage that was
the day the one guy called me a monkey
in the audience and during commercial
break I could see them signaling each
other and just watching them and their
behavior I thought oh they get it I
don't get it
they are using me they are using this
platform because they understand because
I'm thinking oh I'm gonna tell you all
about the KKK
they were using it to recruit members
for themselves they were using it to
recruit their base and I then went to
the Boudreaux sisters have not doing a
show like that so they said you're not
gonna do the mistress's you know you
know gonna okay what we gonna do so I
said we are going to create a baseline
for ourselves that's based on intention
this was around 1989 when I'd read
Gary's Zhukov's book called the seat of
the soul and that book was life-changing
for me because in it he talked about the
power of intention and that cause in
effect what goes out comes back is
determined by your intention the energy
of your intention is what determines
your life most people don't think about
their intention they just think about
what they wanted to most people don't
think about why they want to do it but
what's going to come back to you the
energy that's going to come back to you
is the real why of why you did it and so
I then said to my producers we're not
gonna do any shows that are not
intentional so don't bring me an idea
unless you have an intention for the
show that you want the outcome to be and
we're gonna strive to see if we can live
up to our intentions and so around the
late 80s we started a pre-show to talk
about what the intention was and then a
post show after every single show to say
did we fulfill that intention and that's
about the time I realized this is bigger
than me now I've got a special bonus cup
from Oprah on how to believe in yourself
that I think you can enjoy but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions let's go from just
watching a video to taking action here
we go question number one where do you
need to better master your craft number
two what does getting in sync with life
look like
number three what are your wounds that
you can turn into wisdom and if you made
it this far in a video and you're still
watching and you promise to take action
after watching this video instead of
just watching another video you're gonna
do something I want to celebrate you
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments as well first day I went to
school I was in a classroom by the time
I was uh you know six years old didn't
go to school - I was six years old cuz I
lived my grandmother there time sure but
she had taught me how to read read the
Bible Bible stories so I went into the
classroom knowing Nicodemus Shadrach
Meshach and Abednego I could spell all
of those words I thought I was you know
I was preaching to the to my
kindergarten teacher at Nova
she was like who is this girl so I was
never placed in an environment where I
was ever made to feel inferior I always
felt like I'm the smartest kid in this
room and because I was never placed in
it but never put in a position where I
was made to feel less than I didn't grow
up feeling less than you know and there
is that this day is history and the rest
is history and it's all about what you
believe you know I say this too when I
do something on my network now call life
class the fundamental key to success is
what you believe is true for yourself
not what you want not what you desire is
what do you believe you know you can say
I wanted I want to be the most
successful person in the world but if
you believe that there's a glass ceiling
and you're gonna have a hard time
kicking through that glass ceiling
curiosity would be defined by the glass
ceiling and the great beauty and gift of
my life is that I was never defined by
the box that other people tried to put
me in
if you want motivation to change your
life check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I have found that every time I
failed I move closer to the goal don't
discount yourself